[Musique]
c'est le nouveau macbook pro elles sont
pour un fabricant de vêtements c'est ça
alors pourquoi personne ne porte de haut
[Musique]
tu parles avec qui je tisse adpa pas
avec mon ami chalet californie il est
lycéen il joue dans l'équipe de
volleyball de son école il est
intelligent et hyper marron il est
encourageant il est gentil et il trouve
magnifique
[Musique]
salut charlie
tu es où chercher sur le banc à côté de
l'escale a tenu
[Musique]
parce qu'elle agit là
je n'arrête pas d'y penser je suis en
colère parce que j'ai rien vu venir
t'es sûr que ça va
peut-être qu'ils m'aiment pas tu été
agressée at il pas passé comme ça tu es
toi tu reconnais ma main
cameron
elle a besoin de toi je veux que ce type
de la maison
battus
car plus rien ne sera jamais pareil
on peut tous souffrir la seule chose
qu'on peut faire c'est être présent pour
ramasser les morceaux qu'on l'ait très
mais vraiment
[Musique]